hi drew i'm farnoosh and here's today's
money moment saving money is important
now more than ever and shoring up cash
can be as simple as making a few phone
calls the trick is to be proactive the
savings won't arrive on your doorstep
you need to make the call for example
credit card companies are reducing
interest rates eliminating fees and
allowing some customers to defer monthly
payments just dial the 800 number on the
back of your card and ask about any and
all types of financial relief your cable
company could also drop your rate
especially with so much competition out
there they don't want to lose your
business simply asking customer service
how can i save on my cable bill this
month could lead to discounts and deals
maybe even a free month's worth of
service finally if you're driving your
car less these days then you probably
shouldn't be paying the same for car
insurance and while some companies are
automatically reducing bills for
customers you may want to call and
confirm you could save as much as 15 a
month